my question to you is uh I know you have
been putting out a lot of videos a lot
of singles freestyles are you working on
an album right now
yeah [__] rap dog I think about it right
there just drinking just looking at it
like [__] rapie of the Year Rookie of
the Year and I'll still sell it out
that's the album The album's called
Rookie of the Year it's hard so called
Rookie of the Year Rookie of the Year
it's the best [__] that I ever wrote in
my life they got my sound out of me all
this [__] you guys think is hard hell no
you get a preview with like the Grio
stuff just the the the Cheeto flow like
those are like the songs they just add
and they're getting like 150,000 70
80,000 in one day on YouTube I trip out
what hey how much is start from scratch
got right now please while I do it yeah
Rookie of the Year man Lefty Gunplay by
OTR records produced by Z Keys South
Trey Matt bricks all Cy features you got
oh man I got big sad 1900 I got Drummer
Boy I Got King cash I got hour 9,000
that ain't [__] it's probably more than
that that ain't nothing probably the
views ain't caught up yet you got to
look at that from the YouTube Studio he
knows he knows eras it and that sounds
hard I want to hear it right now yeah
shit's hard hey no um big sad Lil weiro
Lil Maru um shout out to San Diego shout
out little Mar we doing the baby I can't
keep my eyes off you and I'm
but he's writing what he's writing and
I'm going I got a thing for the rock P
you yeah that was the Big G record remix
that that beat and uh that's the song
that I told him I wanted him on I see
him on it and I think he's going to do
numbers him see when you when you do
that record you got to hit a big Gemini
to get it cleared you got to just remake
the beat dog to whoever can make the
beat better memorize it in your are
y'all clearing the Big Gemini sample yep
yeah through George New
Mexico yeah they said it's good that's
just hard That's a classic going do
money y'all got to remake some MB Riders
[__] no MC Magic
[__] that that say baby no I know but
I'm saying you should also remake some M
like did you ever grow up listening to
MC Magic all my girls did all my mom did
my mom and all her own girls did yeah
that's like the girls and the mom stuff
like uh nah can't oh yeah I should do it
for the people why not for the culture
yeah for the culture they would really
like that shout out to other girls that
grew up listening to that and I'm like
you should you should do a free hey you
know what we're gonna have You Freestyle
before you leave over I'mma pick the
beat let me hear which beat we're GNA do
neighborhood music a little Rob be yeah
I think that'll be hard D that was going
to be hard to do and then like then Su
all right we can do summer nights that's
it no or or neighborhood neighborhood oh
I could do it like that I like this song
neighborhood it's all good we'll get to
that later it'll be want do it right now
already well no it'll be a different
YouTu I met L Rob the other day man
shout out to L Rob man man OT took me
over there to a to a little Rob concert
on a Sunset Boulevard in Melrose yeah um
he took me I met him he was real humble
he's just like real like just a hum you
know super I sa local too like Sao Sao
is cool he's cool as [__] too he's
really cool he's like gang gang like
he's just like Hood with it like he's
just he is Woody like he says he's just
like he's he's a gangster sa Bo's a
gangster like you meet him in person you
be like oh [__] he a g he real woman
recognize real he he L like he a
gangster you know I always wondered is I
didn't think he was going to be like
that
I he surprised the [__] out of me he's
really like that like he's just really
tripping saboy lo I met him randomly
backstage at a y concert in Arizona
before he went to jail the last time
he's cool huh I mean he was cool yeah he
look like a homie like yeah that's s Boy
Lo shout out s Boy Lo on YG 4 uh I was
PE slim man I was gonna ask you yeah rip
to slim 400 uh